let's read this first story from the New
York Post ladies and gentlemen Putin
demands unfriendly countries use rubles
to buy Russian oil and gas
Russia was hit with crippling economic
sanctions after it launched a massive
military campaign against Ukraine a
month ago but efforts to isolate Russia
economically are Complicated by the fact
that the European Union is dependent on
Moscow for oil and natural gas that is
used to heat homes during the winter
with the financial news tightening and
the European Union split on whether to
sanction Russia's energy sector Putin
hit back with a clear message if you
want your guess buy our currency Russia
will continue of course Supply natural
gas in accordance with volumes and
prices fixed in previously concluded
contracts Putin said in a televised
meeting with top government ministers
imagine being NATO and the EU and not
seeing this coming this is this is Joe
Biden's efforts I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna I gotta blame Joe Biden for this
one I mean this is his administration in
the United States very much so the U.S
leads NATO
Vladimir Putin effectively getting off
the Petro dollar requiring Europe to buy
oil and gas in Rubles it's it's it's
it's it's breaking the one thing the
United States actually has control over
or what the one thing that we actually
get value out of and is that we control
our own currency which we make everybody
buy to buy oil
so this is going to be a global
fracturing a global parallel economy is
emerging already we heard that Saudi
Arabia was in discussions with China to
start buying oil in Yuan
threats of World War III chaos prices
going through the roof how you guys
doing it's part of the plan definitely I
mean besides inflation and like the
supply chain breaking up and you know
there's transgender swimmers beating out
women and we're having gay pride parades
in Children's Schools teaching them how
to tuck their scrotum to their butthole
and Children's medical hospitals true
story
um big big big uh sidestep from Vladimir
Putin and gas prices yeah well I was
going to say besides all that obviously
the best thing that I've heard all year
is that our money might lose all of its
value and it might actually be worthless
and I know this is on purpose because I
mean if you think about destabilization
of Venezuela talk about the invasion of
Libya you even talk about a little bit
what was going on in Syria and what
happened in Iraq When leaders tried to
take the oil trade off the U.S dollar if
they try to do anything right the global
currency or the African currency in
Libya I mean you end up getting
sodomized and murdered in your own
country yes yeah I know you get you get
hung you get you get let out and so I
mean if for the last like one 100 years
especially last few decades if somebody
tried to do this we basically just wiped
them out it makes me wonder if we're
going to allow this to happen
specifically not just with the ruble but
also with Saudi Arabia and specifically
the yuan in China is this part of Klaus
Schwab's World economic Forum idea to
sort of destabilize one Empire and
create a trifecta in this movement
people give that guy way too much credit
I think he's a bad guy I think not him
but the world economic forum is is a is
an agreement among nations to kind of
see us like a lot of bureaucrats
specifically like in Washington
obviously don't see America as the
greatest country in the world we're like
a country and there's this movement
towards a central currency haven't you
read about the liberal World Order
the liberal World Order yeah yeah you're
not familiar uh enlighten me uh let me
let me let me see if I can pull it up
yeah I'm like so there's another world
order that we need to be paying
attention no no no no no you need to
understand when they're talking about
the new world order they're talking
about the end of the liberal world world
order and the emergence of a new world
order so this is the Council on Foreign
Relations website certified by newsguard
100 out of 100 what is the liberal World
Order
after World War II the deadliest
conflict in human history countries
sought to ensure the world would never
again devolve into such terrific
violence world leaders created a series
of international organizations and
agreements to promote Global cooperation
on issues including security trade
health and monetary policy the United
States has championed this system known
as the liberal world order for the past
75 years during this time the world has
enjoyed unprecedented peace
unprecedented peace and prosperity you
know I would dispute that last sentence
but um I wouldn't dispute everything
else they're saying the Council on
Foreign Relations overtly says after
World War II Global cooperation from
powerful world leaders creating
International organizations sought to
secure the planet
um you know creating policies on
security trade health and monetary
policy when Joe Biden says that there's
going to be a new world order this is
what the New World Order means when Bush
said it when H.W bush when Clinton when
Hillary Clinton when they all say this
what they're saying is the liberal World
Order will come to an end and there will
be a new world order well you know
what's that specifically called I don't
know this rhetoric is the exact same
rhetoric that you read in the un's
agenda 2030. I actually printed that out
I was reading through it this is the
exact same type of thing that they're
trying to propose right this
utopian-like Society where everything's
great and we have all of these
organizations that are helping the world
pushing peace and prosperity but in
reality we see when put into practice
what this actually looks like look at
our streets right now look at
democrat-run cities if you will look at
liberal policy actually put into play or
inside entire country is in Decay we're
deteriorating from the inside you know
we have a president in office who is
incapable of even forming a coherent
sentence a lot of people say that Joe
Biden has uh you know done a horrible
job as president well he's done a great
job of one thing destroying this country
in record time yeah he did it really
quickly huh yeah really quick Gotta Give
him credit for that I mean wow it feels
like it was tipping and then he stepped
into the pilot seat just as it fell off
the ledge also they did oversee the
printing of like seven or eight trillion
dollars in the last year and a half
which is terrible policy a little bit
problematic you ever uh
Mr I call my dog Mr Magoo you know you
know Mr Magoo like he can't see and so
he's like bumbling around and like
getting into all sorts of shenanigans
you know he's like an old man oh yeah
that's like all the Snows yeah that's
like don't you feel though when you hear
this that we've all been sold a lie and
and I even got duped into this being uh
from Los Angeles like actually born and
raised in in Southern California right
there there was this sort of lie that we
were sold that is clearly unraveled now
that you could have this sort of
liberalism in this Mecca that you could
have your cake and eat it too like you
could have money you could have freedom
you could have immigration you could
have multiculturalism and you could kind
of create this Bastion of Utopia smack
dab in in a desert right even your water
even though you don't have natural water
sources right in L.A and as we've seen
it divulged over the years or or develop
and and also then decline is that it
didn't end up really working that well
because obviously when you have all
these cultures together they ended up
self-segregating LA's one of the most
segregated regions in the country it is
insane it is to the point where you can
like tell you where the Jews live or the
Mexicans live where the El salvadorians
live in Chicago yeah I know what I'm
saying like it's but I'm saying it you
know it obviously is touted as being
diverse but it's really segregated then
the wealth disparity there's a shrinking
middle class I mean and the confusion
the laws are not enforced it's pretty
absolutely crazy so I feel like
genuinely this liberal World Order like
you said that they're doing away with is
an interesting way to get people
complacent because when you create a
liberal Society that's not based on
tradition or nationalism or values but
this idea of personal Liberty
individualism you start getting into
your you know your pot of choice your
vices you get into your porn addictions
you get you you know you uh pursue your
career rather than family and everyone
is just kind of like fighting they give
up their guns they're not focused on
things like self-protection and
Gathering and self-sufficiency Etc and
then we end up kind of concerned there's
a contradiction in there I mean people
who are who believe in individualism
individualism and civil liberties don't
give up their guns well that's what I'm
saying it literally was a deception
because that's what I'm saying they gave
us this form of liberalism this absolute
kind of their developed form of like you
can have peace in your countries the
wars won't be fought there you can make
a lot of money things can be really good
your kids can all go to college and then
once we were all in these places
everyone's on anti-anxiety and
antidepressant pills people are unhappy
they're not satisfied with their lives
if you look at how happy people are
they're not full of joy they're not
content they're not satisfied we're very
divided and now we're all in this place
where we don't have anything to unify us
we don't have a common religion not even
really a common language because I'm not
talking about Spanish like have you ever
heard someone under 16 talk I don't not
lately I can't I can't tell what they're
talking about yeah but like like it's
like yeah I just I just meant they
divided us
lead speak is a millennial thing dude
yeah what is this it's l-33t lead speak
it's just the way you type like Words
faster with numbers
one three three seven yeah but that's
that's an internet culture thing that
goes back a long time I mean if you're
talking about the slang terms used by
kids yeah but that's what I'm saying
those that language is changing in a way
where it's like each generation can't
even effectively communicate with each
other not just through language but
through the mediums are changing so
rapidly even look at the app development
and app usage based off of age range I
mean we are divided and categorized to a
point to where it's the perfect time to
where we can't even we can't even agree
on basic things like on you know people
are still divided on what happened in
2020 people today can't even agree on
the most basic science and what is a man
what is a woman it's a perfect opportune
time to to to to retire the current
liberalism and then Institute whatever
the hell you want because we're too
divide and two weak and complacent I
believe to really effectively fight
anything like I don't think there's
anything to fight for like we don't we
don't even know what we would be
fighting to preserve there's a great
meme right now where it says it shows
the clip from the world from the world
economic Forum saying you will own
nothing and you'll be happy then it says
you know journalists say the great reset
is a conspiracy theory and the next one
is the Bloomberg article saying give up
meat for lentils let your dog die
nothing and you'll be happy I I wanted
to pop in on what you were saying too on
the entire manipulation of our language
so he and I were actually having a
conversation on the way up here and it's
kind of insane how we now are saying
biological male or biological female now
we're saying actual science as opposed
to what the left's version of science is
the language has been so manipulated now
that like Elijah said in the common day
we can't even just decide on what basic
science is anymore well I I kind of
disagree I think what happened is you
have like American society moving up and
then at some point the left started
butting off like some kind of fungus
like I mean that like I don't I don't
mean that's disparaging I mean literally
like fungus Buds and then you know
separates yeah and that's what it is
like so people who are in the middle or
on the right who believe you know words
have meaning and you know uh history
exists stayed going down the same path
following history following the lessons
of our ancestors and then this new group
of people split off and they have a
different language they have a different
world view they believe crazy things
different reality really totally
different reality yeah yeah so it's it's
not if you were to say that language
changed it would be to imply that those
people have legitimacy now I certainly
think they control institutions I
certainly think that they how they're
not legitimacy though I mean if you have
power that's what's kind of cool that's
their mentality is there's no truth but
Power I disagree I think they're
completely illegitimate because they
make up random words that are
meaningless and you ask a Supreme Court
Justice to find women it's just I can't
and I'm like okay you're illegitimate
and incompetent if you can't Define a
basic word the same woman who said I
can't Define the word woman literally a
minute later said Roe v Wade is about a
woman's right to terminated pregnancy
and I'm like what what are you talking
about you just said you didn't know what
it was you couldn't Define the word
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there